[Music]  [Music]  mine got rotational  [Music]  [ __ ] me BJ Blazkowicz Caroline you're  alive if you call shooting in a bag  living three pulverized vertebrae you  head trauma 4 inches of cast iron  shrapnel right in the [ __ ] still in  there  severed : septic shock shattered pelvis  memory loss flashbacks 14 years in a  loony bin good to see you William  friends and comrades this is it the  Nazis stole our seagulls they used them  the wind the world everything they have  accomplished was built upon our  knowledge  say think supports over  to feel weak beaten  don't have some extra Polson as others  say blasts coffee stand fighting after  all these years goddess Athena powers in  the end we will be judged not by what we  have destroyed but what we have created  me a man destruction like what you  always do  it's just you doing you  wake up your dad  dr. Blasco heads  shooting stabbing strangling Aziza  [Music]  let's go [ __ ] what's your status  well I'm on the [ __ ] moon